we've already seen multiple examples of
doing something like dividing 176 by 8
and we're gonna do it again but this
time we're gonna use we're gonna you try
to visually understand why what we're
doing actually works so we've seen you
take an 8 and you divide it into 176 176
actually for practice it doesn't hurt if
you want to pause the video and try to
work through it on your own so the way
that we've thought about it in the past
as we said okay well how many times does
8 go into 1 well it doesn't go into 1 so
let's go let's look at the next to the
next digit so how many times does 8 go
into 17 well it goes into 17 2 times 2
times 8 is 16 and then we subtract and
we get 17 minus 16 is 1 and then we
bring down the 6 the 6 that's in the
ones place we say how many times does 8
go into 16 well it goes 2 times 2 times
8 is 16 and then we subtract and we're
done and so how does why why did this
make sense maybe you get this process
that I did this long division process
but why does it actually make sense and
so to think about that let me let me
draw a rectangle we just have remind
ourselves that the area of a rectangle
so if I have a rectangle like this and
if it's it's let's say its height is 5
and once its width is 20 then the area
of this rectangle is going to be 5 times
20 which is equal to 100 square units so
let's think about this is an area
problem so if I had if I had so one way
to think about it is I if my dimensions
are 8 and something else then of my
rectangle that my area needs to be 176
or another way of thinking about it let
me draw it like this so maybe it looks
something like let me draw it like this
I'm not gonna be able to draw it
perfectly to scale so this problem is
essentially saying okay if I have
something with an area of 176 and I know
one of the dimensions I know one of the
dimensions is 8 so I know this dimension
right over here is 8 this boils down to
well how can I figure out what
the length is what this this what this
dimension up here is going to be so what
is that dimension up here going to be if
we did that that we know what eight 176
divided by eight is because eight times
this thing is going to be 176 so let's
let's draw the parallels between what we
did here and how we can think about this
thing right over here so we said okay
eight doesn't go into one eight goes
into 17 and I said it goes into 17 two
times but you have to pay attention to
the place value here did I really say
eight goes into 17 two times and that is
the way I thought about it but what's
really going on here
this one is in the hundreds place the 7
is in the tens place this is 170 so I
really said that 8 goes into 170 not two
times notice I put this 2 in the tens
place I'm saying 8 goes into 170 20
times so one way to think about it is
let me let me erase this so we know that
area has a total of 176 and every 576
one way to think about it is I split
this into 170 and 6 so maybe it looks
something like this so I'll draw it like
so one way to think about it this
section right here has an area of 170
and then this area right over here would
be 6 another color it would be say X
fair enough right the a total area still
176 is still 176 so over here when I
looked at the 17 which is only really
170 I said well how many times does 8 go
into 170 I said it goes 20 times this 2
in the tens place is 20 so it goes 20
times
let me just this orange color so I could
say okay this length right over here
maybe is this length right over here is
20 so it goes 20 times now what's 20
times 8 well 20 times 8 would be this
rectangle that would be this rectangle
right over here which of course 20 times
has that would be give us an area of 160
160 so let me whoops let me erase this
so this right over here and I should
probably erase it with a thicker thing
this right over here is going to be
equal to 160 that's what this 16 right
over here is notice this in the hundreds
place this is in the tens place this is
a hundred and sixty this is a hundred
and sixty 160 now if you subtract that
from 170 what do you have left over you
have this ten you would have this ten
left over and that's what this is right
over here that's this ten notice we
haven't changed the whole that we still
have we still add up to 176 160 plus 10
plus six
176 now we see that the eight times 20
gives us the 160 so now we have to
figure out what the remained or what
we're how to divide eight into what's
left over well what's left over well we
have this 10 and six we have this 10 and
six right over here
well what is the 10 and six one way to
think about it we got the tent then we
brought down the six that's the
equivalent of adding 10 plus 6
equivalent of adding 10 plus 6 which is
equal to which is equal to 16 this thing
right over here has an area of 16 well 8
goes into 16 how many times well 8 goes
into 16 2 times and two times and it
goes exactly 2 times 8 well it's gonna
be exactly 16 so what's the dimension up
here well it's going to be 20 20 plus 2
20 plus 2 or 22 and we're done so I know
what you're thinking hey sow that was
really involved I wouldn't do that on a
day to day basis if a basis if I'm
trying to compute things really fast and
etc etc and that is true you would
probably do something like this or maybe
even do it in your head but it's really
neat to realize that look there isn't
this isn't just some you know random
voodoo process that someone made you
memorize one day it makes logical sense